[Music]
on this wednesday night a black teenager
in ohio
shot and killed by police mikaya
bryant's final moments
caught on camera it's a tragedy there's
no other way to say it
it's a 16 year old girl police urged the
community to await the facts
plus hope derrick chovin's conviction is
a turning point
african-american people we feel that we
never get justice
too many patients at ontario hospitals
how facilities are freeing up beds
in the covid crisis from crushing the
curve to soaring
infections the crisis in india
now a covert hotspot again
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
there is renewed hope for racial justice
and police reform in the u.s after a
former minneapolis police officer was
found guilty yesterday of murdering
george floyd
today the u.s attorney general announced
the entire minneapolis police department
will be investigated
to determine if there is a pattern of
unlawful policing
though within hours of the verdict
another police shooting was making
headlines
this one happened in columbus ohio a 16
year old black girl was killed
within hours police released body cam
footage and a warning once again
it is disturbing say they were
responding to a call about a disturbance
and
what happened unfolded rapidly the body
cam video shows officers approaching a
driveway where people are fighting
and one teenager armed with a knife
lunges at another
dressed in pink hey what's going on
hey hey hey get down get down
get down get down
an officer fires four shots we have
frozen the video at that point
the girl carrying the knife slumps to
the ground other officers
attempted life-saving measures police
say 16-year-old mikaya bryant who was
living in foster care
died later in the hospital
the outrage and emotion
around this incident a teenage girl
is dead and she's dead at the hands
of a police officer
under any circumstances
that is a horrendous tragedy
but the video shows that there is more
to this
columbus police caution about a rush to
judgment an independent investigation is
underway they say they released the
video quickly to be transparent with the
public
and that officers can fire if someone is
facing a deadly threat
i cannot respond specifically to this
this specific incident but what i can
say
is when officers are faced with someone
employing deadly force deadly force can
be the response the officer gives
protesters took to the streets of
columbus last night in anger officials
say more information
and footage will be released if it
doesn't compromise the investigation
regardless of the circumstances
associated with this
a 16 year old girl lost her life
yesterday
[Music]
i sure as hell wish it had happened the
officer who fired at bryant is nicholas
reardon he has been taken off
street duty mikaya bryant was killed
just half an hour before the verdict in
the george floyd murder case was read
out
and though what happened in ohio is
still under investigation
it is clear the verdict in floyd's
murder is a beginning
not an end mike armstrong has our top
story tonight
remember the jury i will now read the
verdict says even though his freedom was
on the line
derek chovin as the verdict was read
find the defendant guilty
barely reacted oh my god outside the
courthouse
and across the u.s it was a very
different reaction i'm so surprised i
ran up here
i'm shocked i don't even is it true
though that's true
okay guilty on all three counts as it
should be
for many the first wave of relief was
followed by that
disbelief had it really
happened i've heard not guilty so many
times so like my mind was like
did i just did i hear that right now how
nervous people were about a conviction
had a lot to do with their confidence in
the justice system
minnesota's governor says for months
he's felt a difference
i thought the case was solid everything
in my you know heart said they're going
to get the conviction
and then i would talk to black
minnesotans who would say we don't
believe that
it never works that way thank you there
is hope this case
marked a change one thing that helped
with the conviction was
other police officers testifying against
chauvin the floyd family says when an
officer
sees another officer do something wrong
it's their duty
to say something our prayer our fervent
prayer
part of george floyd's legacy is that
this will be a precedent
we have been here before sandra hudson
is one of the founders of black lives
matter canada
accountability for chauvin she says took
a half dozen direct witnesses and a nine
minute video of the killing
most victims and their families don't
usually get so much evidence
yeah it's a really high bar but what the
conviction has then she says
is make public debate about police
powers more mainstream
that's absolutely true we can't stop now
because
this isn't the end one lesson from this
case
some point to is the power of pressure
the organizer of this march in montreal
last spring
says protests made it impossible for
chauvin's actions
not to land him in front of a judge if
it was not for the mobilization
worldwide i don't think this bird will
be the same or i don't think everything
would have happened the same way
the floyd family says it hopes the
movement continues
to turn pain into purpose
mike armstrong global news montreal
derek shovin who now faces up to 40
years in prison will be sentenced in
eight weeks he's being held in an
isolated wing of minnesota's only
maximum security prison oak park heights
the prison says it's because of concerns
for his safety the facility has a
reputation for housing notorious
criminals
chauvin is in solitary confinement and
is allowed out for one hour a day
to exercise in ontario an investigation
is underway after a police officer was
captured on video
shoving a child on a scooter the video
was captured sunday at a skate park in
the town of gravenhurst the park was
closed under ontario's stay-at-home
order the opp
says officers stopped a group of young
people who weren't physically distancing
or wearing masks
the man who captured the video told
global news he believes the incident
was unprovoked some kids were giving
bad mouths but the kid that got pushed
over
he wasn't giving any lip nothing he was
cooperating
the opp says the officer has been
reassigned to administrative duties
pending
an independent investigation there is
more trouble for the ontario government
as it grapples with spiking cases of
covet 19.
premier doug ford is now in
self-isolation after one of his aides
tested positive
the premier's office says ford tested
negative himself yesterday but under
toronto public health guidelines he must
self-isolate
for 14 days hospital icus in ontario
continue to overflow with people sick
with covid19
a record 790 ontarians are now in
intensive care
more than 560 of them are on ventilators
in some hospitals resources are
stretched so thin
patients are now being transferred to
other hospitals around the province
abigail beeman reports on the desperate
moves by a health care system
struggling to keep up finding space and
getting covet positive patients to the
right bed across ontario is so complex
one icu doctor called it critical care
hopscotch
the idea is to create these concentric
circles so we want to be able to keep
receiving
patients from you know that oshawa area
so that oshawa can in turn
take patients from the real super hot
spots dr christie lee's downtown toronto
icu has been accepting patients from
hospitals even more overloaded than hers
in the greater toronto area
while they call in non-icu doctors to
help and are opening a third icu space
surgeons and anesthesiologists that are
basically now
sort of changing their scopes of
practice to come and help us care for
covet patients
in kingston tuesday the icu had 44
patients
43 were from out of town the hospital is
boosting capacity
we are starting to feel the pressure
transferring icu patients is its own
challenge
since january orange's operations center
had about 200 requests a month
in the first three weeks of april alone
570.
so they're quite complex and it can be
difficult to ventilate
so it's unusual for us to do that many
persistently back to back
orange boosted capacity by more than 200
percent
even the chief medical officer has
joined the front lines
we can create more care land ambulances
it's we can't really create any more
helicopters or
fixed-wing aircraft so while it's more
challenging to get a patient from
toronto to
ottawa that city's chief medical officer
says it has accepted about 20 from the
gta
and the first adult has now been
admitted to the city's children's
hospital
we here on a regular basis that be
prepared to take more
each day and so we're not expecting that
to slow down dr simpson of ontario
health says nothing is off the table in
terms of transferring patients so while
the focus is moving patients inside
ontario they're considering the idea of
out-of-province transfers
and even to u.s border cities in new
york and michigan
abigail beeman global news ottawa
ontario is expecting a shortage of more
than 4 000 nurses in the hospital sector
over the next four months and the need
for icu nurses
is most acute they care for the sickest
patients and are sometimes caring
for entire families karen lieberman
spoke to one critical care nurse about
the toll
it is taking he's a younger gentleman
in his 40s he is positive for covid and
he is on the maximum amount of settings
on the ventilator that we can put him on
100 percent
oxygen critical care nurse laura mayling
will spend her shift
focused on this one patient he
facetimed his wife and his kids before
her patient is among the sickest in the
hospital and requires
constant complex care we give them
sedation
and we have to manage their blood
pressure and
giving medications like that can only be
given here in icus
the shifts are grueling and the caseload
can at times feel hopeless
because despite laura's best efforts
many patients
won't survive my patient was very young
in her
40s and she passed away of covid and
it was like we felt so helpless laura is
weeks away from maternity leave
filling her shoes will be challenging in
addition to beds and equipment there's a
need for specialized staff
right now they're just not available and
yet the covid patients
keep coming we do have redeployed staff
that are able to
help assist the nurse in providing care
so we're able to stretch that model a
bit the question of course is
you know how far can we stretch more
than a year into the pandemic
they're stretched thin ontario has the
lowest
around per population in the country the
ceo of the registered nurses association
of ontario says she long warned of a
major nursing shortage in the province
now it's become clear this precious
health care resource is lacking
i made 800 new bets multiplied by four
each plus all the others right the plus
we are putting now
people in other places and you are going
to deplete
every single other unit overnight with
600 mills as laura gets set to leave the
hospital
ontario icu's are becoming ground zero
during this third wave of the pandemic
we're just treading water here in the
icu
like we're just managing karen lieberman
global news
toronto a canadian military member
on why she filed a complaint against
general jonathan vance coming up a
global news
exclusive
the canadian military is facing a
reckoning over allegations of high-level
sexual misconduct
parliamentary committees have been
digging into accusations first reported
by global news and hearing from dozens
of witnesses
but one voice has been noticeably absent
that of the woman who came forward in
2018 with allegations
against the former chief of the defense
staff now she wants to clarify why and
how
she reported general jonathan vance our
ottawa bureau chief mercedes stephenson
has the exclusive details the woman who
general jonathan vance
allegedly sent a now notorious email to
says she wanted the minister of national
defense
harjeet sajin to know about the email
and that she thought the minister
would take action but that's not what
happened
it all started out with this email it's
what was in the envelope military
ombudsman gary
walborne tried to hand minister harjit
sajin in 2018.
inside was an email chain in which vance
who had approached a young woman
corporal
offering career advice suggested if they
couldn't find a convenient time to meet
for a professional coffee or beer in
ottawa
we could throw caution to the wind and
escape to a clothing optional
island in the caribbean global news has
obtained the email
and spoken with the woman we've agreed
to protect her identity as she is now a
reserve military officer
and fears career repercussions she
agreed to talk after repeated requests
by global news
willing to tell her truth vance vastly
outranked the woman at the time of the
email and she was
uncomfortable with the sexual
insinuation she believed vance was
making an
inappropriate joke but beyond that there
was an undercurrent that would bother
her for years
people don't say those things unless
they're testing the waters she said
vance said he doesn't recall sending the
email but that if he did
it was meant as a joke a joke not
allowed under policies he would later
implement
six years later is an officer wanting to
lead by example on sexual misconduct
the woman made the difficult decision to
report the country's top soldier
she approached the military ombudsman
because she knew he would have to go to
the minister
who could do something and she was
concerned about the integrity of
operation honor
and the forces my intent was never to
make this public or widely known she
said
it was for the minister to deal with it
at an appropriate time
and perhaps reconsider how operation
honor was commanded
a time the woman thought like when the
government was deciding on the general's
future
including extending his term the trudeau
government made
vance canada's longest serving chief of
the defense staff he remained in office
for almost three years after the
concerns
were brought forward the liberal
government has defended its lack of
action
saying it couldn't proceed without the
name of the woman
but she says she asked the ombudsman to
protect her identity
and thought the email would be proof
enough for the minister and
others mercedes stevenson global news
ottawa
ahead the variant first detected in
india lands in canada what's being done
to
reduce the risk of its spreading
the variant first detected in india is
now in canada quebec has identified
what's believed to be the first
confirmed case in the country
it's not clear how it got here but there
are still daily flights between india
and canada
and there's concern the variant is
fueling a terrible fourth wave
in india redmond shannon reports
another virus victim
another morning family parts of india
are in the grip of a covid19 crisis
hospitals are short on beds and oxygen
this hospital oxygen leak is being
blamed for
22 patient deaths crematoriums are
working
around the clock and the capital is
among regions currently in lockdown
for months cases dropped in india
leading some to think it had achieved a
type of
herd immunity a naive assumption for a
mutating virus according to dr prabhu
the
sense that the first infection would
take care
and immunize the population really
hasn't occurred
researchers are still trying to
establish whether the b1617 variant
first found in india and now in canada
is more infectious it's undoubtable
that the big spike that's occurring now
is because of these variants
you see them occurring in younger
population you see them occurring in
different geographic areas
ja says it's likely there are more cases
of the variant in canada
that haven't yet been detected i think
there are slightly over 100
such cases that we've identified here in
the in the uk
the uk is about to ban airport arrivals
for all foreigners who've recently been
in india i have asked our officials
to look carefully at for example what
the uk has done
very recently on suspending flights from
india but for now prime minister justin
trudeau says
airport testing and quarantine measures
are effective
in reducing the risk of importing new
variants
not all experts agree personally now
looking into the situation we're in
right now we can't wait for conclusive
evidence
right now the precautionary principle
will tell you
you need to react the better news is
that the specific mutations in b1617
suggest
vaccines should work against the variant
redmond shannon global news london
next a guilty verdict delivers hope for
racial justice in george floyd city
for 11 months the spot on the street
where george floyd took his final
breaths has been ground zero for grief
and outrage
president biden said yesterday his
murder here in the full light of day
ripped the blinders off for the whole
world to see
the systemic racism in america people
have occupied george floyd square to
keep up the pressure for racial justice
and police reform
and as heather urex west reports the
struggle is far from over
for nearly a year the mood in
minneapolis has
been heavy there has been sadness there
has been rage
and this week there has been a lot of
anxiety too
there has just been this tense
you know pregnant feeling in the air
since the jury began its deliberation
so when the verdict came down the sense
of relief was
overwhelming when i heard the verdict i
just screamed and i shouted and i said
thank you guys
last night when i got home i think i was
sleeping for nine
jamar nelson listened to the verdict
from the crowd outside of
court i had knots in my stomach because
i you know again i
i i was hoping that he got convicted on
the third degree
and the manslaughter um was not
anticipating
that he would be convicted on all three
counts but nelson knows
there is still so much work left to be
done
will the derrick chovin's trial was
taking place in nearby brooklyn center
another black man
20-year-old dante wright was killed by
another member of the police
kim potter has been charged with second
degree murder
she too should face faced justice
and the arm of the law the murder of
george floyd sparked global protests
as painful as his final moments were to
watch they were also
impossible to ignore i'd say overall
this verdict feels like a brief bit of
relief
right it feels like a measure of
accountability
which many people doubted could happen
here but palmisano admits in minneapolis
nothing has been fixed
the city is still grappling with how its
police department should be reformed
still the importance of this moment in
time
cannot be discounted these things help
because now it can incur you can now
encourage
our black and brown boys and girls to
become officers to change
to be the chains that they want to be
and so
while there is no joy with this verdict
there
is hope heather urex west global news
calgary and that is global national for
this wednesday i'm donna friesen
this is queen elizabeth ii's birthday
she turns 95 today
but there is no celebration it has been
just four days since the funeral of her
husband prince philip
buckingham palace released a photo in a
statement thanking people for the many
good wishes and saying
well as a family we are in a period of
great sadness it has been a comfort to
us all to see
and to hear the tributes paid to my
husband
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye-bye
[Music]